[Música]
bueno a ver si me escucho bien creo que
sí verdad
empezamos bien este esta conferencia
bueno como acaban de escuchar esta
plática se llama que ser nerd si sirve
en la vida pero primero que nada tenemos
que preguntarnos qué es esto de de ser
nerd muchas veces lo decimos como
insulto incluso no así de ayuda enseñar
mire sener pero creo que eso ha cambiado
a ciertas fechas sobre todo conforme
nosotros nos vamos haciendo más nerds
todos
conforme más tiempo pasamos en las
computadoras y antes eso era propio de
nerd conforme vamos conociendo más de
superhéroes todos sabemos más de
superhéroes ahorita de lo que sabían los
nerds hace 15 años las cosas están
cambiando y ahorita se diría que la
venganza de los nerds porque como la
película porque las cosas van cambiando
y entre más cerebro tengas en más cosas
estás mejor preparado para muchas cosas
ahorita estoy hablando con ustedes que
son gente del tec de monterrey o sea es
gente que me parece que ustedes son
gente que tiene que echarle ganas eso no
es lo mismo en todos lados yo soy de la
unam
en la unam me parece que sobresale el
que quiere sobresalir y el que no el que
es mediocre no sobresale o sea puedes
nadar de muertito por así decirlo en la
unam y me parece quiero creer que aquí
en el tec todos le echan muchas ganas
por muchos o por muchos factores por las
colegiaturas por la competitividad por
la cultura de la empresa de
emprendimiento que tienen ustedes todas
esas cosas son buenas y las admiro y yo
me atrevo a decir que son nerds en cada
una de las cosas que hacen por ejemplo
hace rato estaba platicando con algunos
de los compañeros que me trajeron acá me
decían que son ingenieros en sistemas
por ejemplo qué bueno ingeniero hay de
todo en esta escuela no hay este
diseñadores gráficos hay diseñadores
industriales hay muchos ingenieros y me
atrevo a creer que todos ustedes son ers
en lo que hacen pero yo creo que ser
neer te es más que eso y es tener
curiosidad natural curiosidad natural
por un montón de cosas curiosidad por el
pueblo donde naciste curiosidad por
la geografía de un el lotero curiosidad
por cómo funciona tu reloj
cómo se hace esta película como estoy
ahorita siendo transmitido en la
pantalla de una imagen de facebook
toda esa es curiosidad y creo que es más
importante que nunca ampliar la tenemos
a nuestra disposición ahorita el
internet podemos ver todo o podemos
quedarnos en facebook chismeando lo que
hizo mi ex novia podemos hacer muchas
cosas pero todo depende de la curiosidad
que tengamos entonces yo les voy a
platicar un poquito de mi experiencia y
les quiero demostrar o por lo menos de
mi experiencia que si sirve sterner
porque creo que a mí me ha funcionado
estoy orgulloso de donde estoy y me
falta mucho por llegar pero creo que con
la idea de ser nerd vamos a llegar lejos
no nada más yo sino muchos de ustedes
vamos a ver cómo funciona esto esto es
parte de ser nerd la curiosidad de ver
si funciona
estoy regresando la verdad
flores
está regresando
es con este o con cuáles ahí está
victoria
fracaso me puedes ayudar
a veces es con este mes
a donde apuntó
[Música]
eso cambia todo
por lo menos ya sé cuál es el botón y
hacia donde tengo que ir a ver listo
bueno empezamos a esta conversación en
serio yo soy locutor y soy ilustrador me
podrán ubicar a la mejor sí y algunos de
ustedes son de la ciudad de méxico
estuvo un riego un tiempo en reactor
105.7 yo soy de la ciudad de mexico y
esa es una de las estaciones que más
queremos es heredera de radioactivo de
órbita ya no trabajo ahí pero durante el
tiempo que trabaja ahí que fueron tres
años fui locutor de estos dos programas
no meteorito que fue fui titular yo en
donde era un programa de corte de
ciencia ficción y baño vaquero que era
matinal todos ustedes saben de dónde
viene la frase baño vaquero porque te
bañas la cabeza y ya saben que no se
saben cómo va el resto de la frase
espero que ubiquen eso y pues nada las
imágenes las hice yo porque como les
comentó soy locutor y soy ilustrador
después de que salí del reactor 105 me
he dedicado a los post podcasts
electrónicos me he dedicado a grabar y
producir yo mi propio material a la
mejor ustedes les gusta game of thrones
les gusta y tengo un podcast que tengo
la fortuna de que fue el número uno de
descargas de itunes méxico durante esta
semana que se llama valedor margulis así
lo pueden buscar y ahí
bueno me encontrarán
en formato podcast también estoy
grabando un podcast que se llama el hype
que es de cultura pop y donde platicamos
de muchas narradas hoy y eso es una
sorpresa para mí me acabo de enterar de
qué estoy aquí junto a ustedes porque
una persona que nos escuche en el
podcast dijo el el creo que sería una
buena idea para venir a practicar con
ustedes y por eso les agradezco mucho
eso es una de las pruebas de cuánto
puedes sacar de cosas que a la mejor en
su momento parece que no tienen sentido
cómo grabar un podcast por el que nadie
te paga luego pasan estas cosas y te
invitan a pueblo o sale en otras
oportunidades lo que lo que es
importante es que lo hagas aunque no
veas en ese momento un beneficio real y
tangible que podrían ser dinero o que
podrían ser mejores números
mucha gente ahorita quiere compartir en
internet en youtube a lo mejor no van a
ver los buenos números de inmediato no
muchos chavos ahorita quisieran ser
estrellas youtubers estrellas d
de internet quieren ser famosos en
instagram a lo mejor no lo van a ver de
inmediato pero creo que vale la pena que
sean nerds y que atraigan a otros nerds
en el sentido de que la gente que está
escuchando el podcast del hype me queda
claro que es gente que está bien
posicionada en cosas que les permite
hacer por ejemplo este tipo de eventos
nerds ya manera y eso es algo muy bonito
en donde empiezas a platicar con gente
con la que tienes que ver y empiezan a
surgir proyectos muy interesantes
seguramente en esta reunión detectó que
van a salir algunos proyectos entre
nosotros o entre la gente ahorita que
está sentada a lo mejor no todos ustedes
se conocen pero si ya están ahorita en
una charla ted que se trata de ser nerf
ya tienen algo en común y a lo mejor
puede salir un proyecto interesante por
ahí ahora vamos a seguir platicando como
les comentaba lo ya ya ya domine el
botón de cambiar la diapositiva y somos
imparables como les comentaba yo soy
ilustrador yo soy de la unam y desde
hace mucho tiempo me he dedicado a esto
esto es trabajo de hace unos 10 o 15
años
y empezar a trabajar con marcas de baile
en la revista bebé mundo
cuando trabaje en la editorial televisa
con las revistas maxim haciendo algunas
portadas como de woody allen o de café
tacuba trabajando sobre todo con un
programa que bueno se llama photoshop y
todos conocemos incluso es un verbo no
photoshopear
hubiera estado bien quedarse ahí pero yo
en ese tiempo yo tenía trabajo en una
agencia de publicidad y les dejé me les
comentó que no me gustaba no me gustaba
porque era completamente absorbente y
muchas veces no haciendo lo que yo
quería yo no soy partidario de decir
sigue tus sueños y todo va a salir bien
creo que nada además de seguir tus
sueños tienes que tener constancia en
esto y les estoy hablando de que esto
fue hace 10 o 15 años cuando yo no era
feliz en una agencia de publicidad y
este era mi proyecto laterales era mi
proyecto que llegaba a ser después de
trabajar en una agencia de publicidad
quedándome a dormir hasta las 2 de la
mañana cuando antes podía no hace hace
15 años y podía desvelar me y no se me
notaba pero no era lo que yo quería
entonces poco a poco dije me voy a salir
de la confianza de la de la del cheque
constante de la quincena y voy a empezar
a hacer mi trabajo y empezó a hacer
ilustraciones en donde aprendí el
concepto de lo importante que es ahorita
lo viral que compartir las cosas con
internet como decía ahorita ya qué
no importa si lo ven tres personas solo
vieron un auditorio o lo ve alguien en
australia o si la persona de una escucha
del hype me invita a esto lo que es
importante en estos tiempos es compartir
y van a encontrar un público estoy
seguro de eso a qué me refiero con ser
nerd sirve por ejemplo esta ilustración
se hizo viral quizá la vieron quizá no
porque ya tiene como 10 años esto pero
me gusta este ejemplo porque lo que
quiso hacer es como una una especie de
de viaje de bitácora de viaje de por
ejemplo de magallanes cuando estaba
descubriendo américa o del barón
humboldt pero con las garnachas
mexicanas con el trompo de tacos al
pastor la torta cubana que comemos en la
ciudad de mexico que es enorme y a mí me
parece que estás garnacha son como el
bestiario mexicano entonces por eso le
di este look de bestiario de del barón
humboldt y de lo que encontró en sus
viajes por la ganadería mexicana no es
importante para un ilustrador tener un
lenguaje visual que le permita decir a
ésta
he ido a hacer algo con el barón
humboldt con la con la estética del
barón humboldt en lugar de no sé hacer
siempre lo mismo que vemos en facebook
vectores se puede romper el paradigma
que de eso se tratan estas pláticas
tecno el trabajo siguió ya trabajado
tengo el gusto de trabajar ahorita con
algunas cosas con dos de las cosas que
más me apasionan como les comentaba a mi
podcast es de cultura pop me encantan
las series y he trabajado algunas cosas
con hb o a nivel no local de lo que me
apasiona game of thrones y con netflix
con narcos por ejemplo no se sirvieron
la serie de narcos bueno no la viaje
pero lo que lo que empieza como un fan
art lo que empieza como un arte que hace
un fan se convierte después algo
lucrativo porque porque estás buscando
porque tienes la las ganas de de saber
un poco más de lo que se había antes eso
me ha llevado a hacer algún par de
libros en editorial planeta para niños
un libro de memes que se llama ay si hay
si un libro de memes que es una
recopilación especie
de almanaque de los memes del 2015-2016
imaginen si no tienes que tener
curiosidad para sumergirte a facebook y
a las redes para sacar todo lo que se
puede publicar porque no todos los memes
se pueden publicar se los aseguro
esta curiosidad de la que me precio
bueno que espero que todos tengan me ha
hecho siempre querer mucho a méxico y
toda la biodiversidad que tienen ustedes
aquí en puebla no está la situación tan
mal como en la ciudad de mexico a nivel
ecológico pero tienen que cuidar mucho
la ciudad porque no quieren terminar
como nosotros en donde ya para nosotros
los de la ciudad de méxico ya los las
especies de méxico son un animal es un
poco fantásticos porque ya ni siquiera
los vemos lo que empezó como un proyecto
de hacer 365 dibujos uno por día donde
dije yo
bueno pues de dónde voy a sacar
inspiración pues de méxico empecé
haciendo un animal endémico por estado
de la república por ejemplo la vaquita
marina que saben que están en peligro de
extinción de baja california
el ajolote que es de la ciudad de mexico
el claro h que en realidad han en todos
lados pero tenía que poner algo para
para guanajuato y no hay una especie que
nada más de este ahí baja california sur
si está el borrego cimarrón pero
entonces esta curiosidad me llevó a
decirle a la
nacional de biodiversidad los encargados
de la biodiversidad en mexico en todo
nuestro país me acerqué a ellos y les
dije en facebook
hola hice algunas ilustraciones les
gustaría compartirlos me mandó a llamar
el titular de la secretaría de una de la
comisión nacional de biodiversidad y me
dijo no no nos gustaron nos gustaron
tanto tus cosas que no las queremos
compartir
queremos encargarte 200 especies para
que las hagas y las distribuya mos en
todos los mecanismos oficiales en todos
los organismos oficiales de méxico
hicieron este mapa que pueden comprar en
las librerías educal pero lo más
importante es que la habana las van a
ver en museos zoológicos y página web
del gobierno para la difusión tan
importante de las especies animales
entonces a eso me refiero con ser nerd
funciona
werner funciona y por eso me gusta lo
que les comentaba conectar con otros
nerds hay un formato de conferencia
llamado pecha kucha es a nivel global es
una especie de texto más corto mucho más
corto que esto
pechakucha en japonés significa
cuchicheo el cuchicheo es una plática de
7 minutos en donde tienes que exponer
tus tu presentación pueden ver allá
arriba que es 20 x 20 20 slides 20
segundos cada una con ellos bueno me da
mucho gusto que he trabajado los
carteles de un tiempo para acá del 29 de
octubre del me parece 2015 a la fecha
esto de conectar con diferentes nerds
pues me ha llevado a hacer carteles con
otras iniciativas de allá de la ciudad
méxico como el drink and drop
para ganar ganarme unos carteles para
una promoción de carteles de las
tortugas ninja a nivel internacional y
pues en general vivir de esto que es
algo difícil el diseño gráfico nos dicen
más en la unam se los aseguro nos dicen
está muy mal pagado es una locura que
estudies eso pero si sabes a dónde vas
que es algo que alguien dijo en estas
pláticas se hace más fácil creo que fue
una cita de saint exupéry cuando el
mundo ve a una persona donde que sabe
dónde van por lo menos hace un ladito y
a lo mejor no sabe exactamente hacia
dónde va esa persona pero sabe que tiene
que trabajar para eso entonces pues
carteles de aliens de radiohead imágenes
de bandas todo esto lo he hecho para
seguir lo que yo quería no trabajar en
la agencia de publicidad y ya llevo como
15 años de hacer esto
y va saliendo bastante bien voy a
platicar de uno de mis mejores ejemplos
de éxito creo que es que he hecho la
imagen de la cerveza indio de dos años
para acá no sé si ustedes tomen cerveza
espero que en el campus no más les vale
y no sé asistir si toman cerveza les
gusta la indio o les gusta la sol y no
podemos ser amigos pero la cerveza indio
tiene algo muy interesante que pocas
marcas mexicanas hacen que es tomar
riesgos tomar riesgos con el empaque por
el adn de la marca que es juego es
juvenil es rebelde y es como de noches y
de rebeldía y de música pero también es
de las pocas que se atreve a cambiar su
empaque a lo largo de más de tres años
más de dos años ya llevamos con este
tipo de campañas otras es muy difícil se
estudian mercadotecnia convencer al
cliente de cambiar el producto porque el
logo es el logo el logo es intocable y
no pero como me van a ver me van a de
reconocer en la tienda no indios y se
toma este riesgo y con una agencia
montalvo ellos se acercaron a mí y me
dijeron necesitamos que coordinen a los
ilustradores para una campaña nacional
de barrios indio que así se llama la
campaña en donde yo le entre al quite
para sugerir barrios para decir eso está
bueno pero este no tan bueno bla bla bla
y al final logramos una campaña que si
la vieron espero que les haya gustado
hay varios lugares de puebla por ejemplo
en la primera en la primera fase estaba
el barrio del artista el callejón del
artista barrio del artista barrio del
artista es analicé yo pero por ejemplo
hice la roma de la ciudad de mexico y
ahora el coordinador dice la rama de la
ciudad de mexico e hice xochimilco yo
estudié en xochimilco ahí estaba mi
escuela entonces cuando estábamos
repartiendo los barrios yo dije
xochimilco es mío no y la rumba bueno
pues vivo ahí entonces tienes que
apartar y tienes que saber qué es lo que
tiene cada lugar en común porque es
bueno ser nerd es bueno ser nerd y saber
de los ajolotes eso sí mi hijo de la
tradición floral de las trajineras es
bueno saber que en la roma están unos de
los pocos
representan bueno esta de la poca
representación de arte coi de nuevo en
méxico entonces tienes que incluir ese
tipo de cosas
werner te va a ayudar en todo todo tu
trabajo porque no te va a hacer tener
que investigar todo porque ya tienes un
bagaje cultural que puedes aprovechar
coyoacán por ejemplo sabemos que es el
lugar de frida kahlo y que los coyotes
son muy importantes entonces puedes
agarrar un poco la estética de frida
kahlo e intentar plasmarlo en vectores y
bueno luego la realidad se impone y no
no me permitieron usarlos los dos lobos
por una cosa de reglamentación de las
marcas entonces la segunda opción pues
fue esta ni modo
polanco polanco tiene que haber un
virrey cierto debe haber un rey tiene
que tener unos lentes pero también
tienen que estar en la estación del logo
del metro polanco por ejemplo que son
las dos los dos ven a 2 de metro polanco
no nada más tienes que hacer cosas
peyorativas y eso les digo con mucho
cariño en méxico tenemos que dejar de
pensar en cosas peyorativas todo el
tiempo en particular un chilango tiene
que ver todo lo malo de sociedad pero
también tiene que buscar un orgullo una
razón de por qué estamos ahí y creo que
se aplica a todo méxico tenemos que
tener mucho orgullo en méxico
lo bonito satélite satélite del estado
de mexico muchísima gente diría uy hay
mucho tráfico hay mucho tráfico pero
también es uno de los exponentes del
urbanismo más bonito de américa latina
que se ha hecho en toda la historia en
1960 estaban haciendo este sueño utópico
de que él
de que la ciudad satélite fue una ciudad
modelo que queda de eso ahorita queda
muy poco pero queda la señalética quedan
las torres de satélite que siguen siendo
hermosas y creo que tenemos que ser
además de nerds optimistas
izamal no sé si conozca en yucatán pero
izamal es un pueblo amarillo es un
pueblo amarillo porque ahí fue juan
pablo segundo y estuvo en la base en la
parroquia de izamal todo el pueblo lo
pintaron de amarillo porque esos son los
colores papales son los colores de la
ciudad del vaticano y es un lugar muy
bonito que si no conocen deberían de
conocer así que de tal forma que cuando
tengan que hacer una etiqueta de la
cerveza indio en su computadora en la
ciudad de méxico ya recuerden que esto
es amarillo recuerden que todo eso es
importante que que los yucatecos por
ejemplo les importa mucho el venado es
uno de sus animales más importantes de
la fauna de allá
campeche campeche mucha gente dice ahí
no hay nada
sí pero evaluarte si hay palmas todo
esto se va consiguiendo a lo largo de
viajes a lo largo de la curiosidad
el mante tamaulipas por ejemplo no
conozco pero me enteré de que es muy
bonito que hay huasteca tamaulipeca y
entonces vamos a hacernos unas plantitas
o nada se evita no pero si conozco por
ejemplo real de 14 y sé que ahí los
hongos si pegan entonces
hay mucho mucha arte que tenemos que
utilizar como mexicano por el orgullo
que tenemos que tener como mexicanos
porque más lo hacen
históricamente más lo han hecho los
extranjeros que nosotros los mexicanos
enorgullecernos del legado gráfico que
tenemos aquí que es incomparable y no se
los tengo que decir pero lo tienen que
recordar bueno esta campaña estuvo en
todo méxico muy hermoso ir a tomarse una
cerveza y decir a veces está cerveza de
la diseñadora no over en polanco en la
ciudad de méxico es de ver los
espectaculares y decir a ese edificio
tiene mi publicidad no es algo padre y
por eso les digo que ser nerd si paga
esta campaña de barrios después creció
hasta los barrios de méxico en eeuu que
es algo muy importante todos tenemos
parientes familiares o viajamos a eeuu y
esta campaña se le ocurrió a la agencia
con la que trabajó montalvo poco antes
de que todo de que alguien se sospechara
que fuera a ganar donald trump entonces
esto en cuanto llegó donald trump al
poder según él
fue muy muy éste
fue muy buen momento el momento fue
perfecto
ahorita muchas muchas marcas se están
forzando la onda y compartiendo hashtags
de hashtag el orgullo de soy mexicano
tenemos que no hacer eso por nada más un
hashtag o una moda o porque ahorita todo
mundo lo está haciendo en mercadotecnia
lo que tenemos que creer lo de corazón y
si nos están escuchando de otros países
creo que aplica a cualquier lugar de
origen pero más en una en un mundo en un
país como méxico en donde necesitamos
más que nunca ahorita por el riesgo de
nivel país necesitamos tener orgullo y
necesitamos recordarle a la gente que
necesite que se le recuerde que somos
parte muy importante del país del norte
en barrios como misión 16 de san
francisco
pilsen de chicago market square puebla
york de nueva york que se llama así
porque hay muchos de las personas que
vivían allá aquí se fueron para allá
está todo esto les comento que yo yo
coordine barrios indio pero no lo hice
todo yo fuimos parte de un equipo
gracias a esto me confiaron a mi hacer
la campaña actual que son carteleras a
la mejor han visto estas de que por
ejemplo esta fue la primera que diseñé
la idea de esta campaña es hacer una una
cartelera temática por estado con que
con un algo del arte típico del estado
de forma minimalista y llegamos a esta
solución por la talavera de pueblo
porque después de muchos intentos hice
como 20 propuestas dijeron sabes que
esto nos gusta porque tenemos que
regresar a la botella de indio clásico
porque si no ya llevamos dos años sin
mostrar la botella de indio entonces
necesitamos algo exactamente cómo esto
encontró les enseñe la edad
talavera de puebla dijeron eso es lo que
queremos después fue más difícil
adaptarla a otros estados por ejemplo en
la ciudad de mexico que tenemos de pavao
pues que le pones pues le pones un
trompo le pones precisamente de todo no
es esta es la idea no un poquito
nuestro nuestro escudo un poquito del
sol escuintla las muñecas se apunte pec
el trompo al pastor en su malla de la
torre latino cosas que nos enorgullecen
de cada estado aquí podemos ver que
regresamos a san luis potosí con bueno
ya nayarit de y con el arte wirikuta con
el arte huichol no oaxaca me gusta mucho
esta porque esta fue fácil para mí fue
tiene que ser alebrijes la cosa y nada
más fue cómo le hago con los alebrijes y
bueno me gusta mucho esta creo que es mi
favorita perdón a los demás estados
chiapas por ejemplo también me gusta
mucho hay muchas opciones de que podrías
hacer con con chiapas pero pues los
jaguares creo que tenían que estar
representados en algún lugar
no
baja california bueno baja california de
repente parece que no hay tanta
actividad humana como que no es difícil
pensar en una artesanía del lugar pero
bueno pues tenemos la naturaleza y ahí
sigo con las vaquitas marinas esa es
otra cosa no lo que ya hiciste en el
pasado lo que trabajasen en la comisión
nacional de biodiversidad lo puedes usar
para otro cliente porque pues hay que
ahorrar tiempo trabajo
mucha gente me dijo pero es que hay más
allá que cocodrilos y pejelagartos y le
dije sí pero yo no lo estoy viendo como
algo malo es un símbolo a mí me parece
espero que los tabasqueños también
campeche los baluartes todo lo que ya
habíamos platicado no toda la historia
de la piratería que es algo único de
todos los de ese estado de en todo entre
todos los demás y bueno ya viene día de
muertos y van a ver otra parte otra la
tercera campaña que hago con indio y
espero que les guste esto no debería
estarlo enseñando pero pues nos van a
inundar con lo de días de muertos
finalmente pues ahorita acabo de hacer
un concurso en la ciudad de méxico de
hacer emoji se diseña los molles de la
ciudad de mexico que estaría muy bien
que hicieran un diseño a los mochis de
la ciudad de puebla espero que lo hagan
pronto yo entré en concurso no gane me
gane una mención honorífica pero no
importa la reacción de los emo les fue
bastante buena la gente me dijo me
gustaron mucho incluso tú debiste haber
ganado yo no sé de eso pero si hay
reacción correcta si hay validación como
decían ahorita a otro compañero desde
parte de la gente a la que va dirigido
tienes que seguir haciendo las cosas
entonces no me desagradó a hacer
hemólisis del ángel de la diana de la
torre latino el monumento a la
revolución la trajinera de xochimilco el
castillo de chapultepec el word trade
center la torta de tamal
los camotes los tacos de canasta los
tacos al pastor el huacal el organillero
la ecobici el metro el taxi el metrobus
el p cero y la camioneta de fierro viejo
varias cosas de estas las compartimos
todo méxico
creo que organilleros creo que ya que
tienen pero bueno tiene muchos
organilleros entonces lo que yo quiero
hacer con esto ya no no hubo concurso no
me gane el premio se van a usar en
teoría para que los descarguen ojalá que
se pueda pero yo no quiero detenerme ahí
por eso voy a seguir adelante perdón yo
sé que en esta ciudad van capeados los
chiles en nogada pero en mi ciudad sin
pan sin capear perdón bang bang sin
bancos sin estar cambiados pero lo que
quiero hacer con esto es seguir haciendo
mochis para representar a méxico porque
porque me gusta el país y porque cerner
te es muy importante y porque nunca
sabes cómo esto va a ser en la puerta
para otra cosa si yo les contara todas
las cosas con como me salen los
proyectos habito ilustración en un
instante un post de instagram de black o
vi una camisa tuya con una ilustración
me puedes diseñar la campaña de
blablabla entonces amplíen sus redes
sean nerds
tengan muchas referencias saquen fotos
viajen mucho siguen el minis siguen ven
instagram soy mario flores sacó buenas
fotos bueno la cosa es viajen porque
méxico y eeuu y todo el mundo vale la
pena ser visitado y vale la pena que lo
recuerden y vale la pena que encuentren
lo que es específico de cada país y que
lo guarden porque nunca saben para que
lo van a usar y no lo digo que tengan
que ser ustedes diseñadores gráficos
pueden usarlo para tantas cosas esto
puede inspirar a un arquitecto o puede
inspirar a un ingeniero para encontrar
una solución un químico puede encontrar
muchas cosas interesantes en hierve el
agua
oaxaca con el manantial que es salado a
la mejor han estado ahí y saben que es
un lugar muy interesante de los que nada
más existen en méxico
saquen fotos porque incluso en un
paradero sucio puede haber belleza nada
más tienen que ser nerds y tienen que
esforzarse un poquito para encontrar el
ángulo interesante muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]